- Welcome to The Next Level
stage my guy T. Murph,
who's from the windy city of Chicago.
(audience applause)
Chi-Town!
Now, I heard that you were a barber..
Before you started doing
comedy which I feel like
is a cheating thing behind your beard.
'Cause you knew how to
manufacture the beard,
but that's another story.
What was that like for you,
I mean from a material basis,
you know, the barbershop is a comedy hub.
- Do you feel like that
was a place where you
perfected your craft, in the barbershop
when you was cutting hair?
- Honestly, yes,
I mean, it's a haven for comedy, man.
I mean, I was one of those barbers, like,
if you come to the barbershop,
you've all had the barber
that spends more time cracking jokes..
- 100 percent.
- Than cutting hair, yeah.
- An hour and a half, two hours?
- You gonna get a whole comedy show
while you wait on this land.
- That's a good thing though!
The barbershop is honestly
the best comedy club, I think.
- Facts.
- Going into the barbershop on a weekend
and having a high level of chemistry
with everybody in there,
that's a good Saturday.
- It is.
- Snapping with everybody in the shop.
Now, because you were a comedian,
do people find themselves
snapping at you more?
- Oh, all the time, man!
You know, cats come in the barbershop,
they feel like they can take you.
You know what I mean, they
come in, they just wanna roast.
And then when you go in on them,
you know, there ain't no
security to break it up.
- No, no, no.
- So, you go in on him, you roast,
and some people's feelings get hurt,
like, 'alright, its enough
with all the little jokes'.
(audience laughs)
'I ain't come here for all that'.
Even though they started it, you know?
- I got a photo, I want you to explain
the photo to me, okay?
- Uh huh.
- What was going on back there?
What was going on right here, man?
- Okay, so those were my first head shots.
- Okay.
- So, after I started
doing stand-up comedy,
you know, you gotta get a head shot.
And I was like, okay, cool,
I'm gonna get a head shot.
So when I went in, I went
in to this photographer
who generally took photos of children.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
- I didn't know!
I didn't know that you
needed to get a photographer
that focused on you, and your
age, and what was going on.
So I went to this..
(audience laughs)
- There's a lot of things
that's wrong with this picture.
I'm gonna tell you, man, you
should've known it was bad
when he said, 'go get your bike'.
(audience laughs)
You are more than ready
for this moment, man.
This is The Next Level for you!
Go out there, and go make Chicago proud!
You all show this man some love right now!
Go do you, boy!